My day in a life as a 25 year old trap wife.
We started our morning activity with watercolors for Wind Week.
Got myself a shower and then I went ahead and fixed stop our room.
I really love opening the windows in the morning.
Practice some piano which I am struggling with.
And then this room just needed picked up.
It was driving me nuts.
My toddler now thinks it's funny to chase me around when I'm vacuuming.
Did our Bible time and some catechism
and then ran out the door to piano lessons.
I've taken lessons since I was about 10,
but recently restarted because I have lost a lot of my skills.
You're never too old to restart something you love.
This is my parents dog and he's attached to my daughter.
Anytime I leave the house this is him through the window.
Got home just in time to start my side dish for dinner.
They're like baked potatoes but cut in half so they cook faster.
After dinner I just unloaded the dishwasher,
reloaded the dishwasher, got it going,
and then at this point I really needed a coffee.
Pick me up away the leftovers
and then I started laundry.
This is like my day in reverse.
Normally start my morning with laundry,
but since I was out of the house for most of the day,
it's just getting done in the evening.
My goal every day is to do one load of laundry
and to Fold one load of laundry.
Now, whether that gets put away is another story.
I ended up putting my kitchen to bed for the night.
Read a little bit in my Kindle.
I kind of just hop around and then watch some hockey with my husband.
Let's go, pens!